opening day for bolden little league
drew in quite the crowd today
as the players stepped back on the field
for more the first time in more than a
year
8 news 9 reporter victoria saha was
there for the event she got the good
assignment today
she joins us live from the newsroom with
more victoria
sasha these young players were stripped
from their passion for baseball last
year when the pandemic
shot everything down and this year they
were able to go back to playing
with some new changes at doodle field
[Music]
opening day at doolittle field came with
a celebration as the bolden little
league baseball team kicks off their
20-21
season the brand new scoreboard was made
possible with a ten thousand dollar
donation from the alpha phi alpha
fraternity
making the comeback on the field extra
special
it hasn't been a tough year and if you
look around you can see the excitement
that the kids have that they're able to
play baseball again and the excitement
was clear brand new uniforms and
equipment ready to be used
i like how we can take turns your
batting
it takes breaks you take breaks so you
don't get overtired
you're playing the teams everybody gets
to have a certain role
in the whole game several members of las
vegas metro police were there and our
very own sheriff lombardo was able to
throw the first
pitch he tells us it's a way for the
west side community to know that law
enforcement
is on their side we want the community
and the kids
in particular to appreciate the cops and
consider them their friend and not their
enemy
this year the league had 130 members but
they made sure to follow covet 19
protocols
so they can have a successful season
being part of the little league baseball
team is something many families in the
west side aren't able to afford but it's
only possible with the help of donations
and sponsors for the 130 players
the sponsors took care of uniforms
equipment and participation fees
in the newsroom victoria saha 8 news now